le vol de la vie le vol de l'espoir
voilà comment certains éditorialistes
argentins ont commenté l'arrivée des
trois cent mille premières doses du
vaccin rue spoutnik vais en provenance
de moscou
l'argentine devient ainsi le premier
pays d'amérique latine à autoriser le
vaccin développé par le centre de
recherche russe gamaleya nous avons reçu
300 mille doses aujourd'hui nous en
viendrons 5 millions de doses du vaccin
ce putsch en guinée en janvier et 14 7
millions de doses ont février avec une
option de cinq l'union des deux
supplémentaires comme nous le disons en
russie c'est dans le besoin que l'on
reconnaît ses vrais amis
nous espérons que notre vaccin elle
devra sauver la vie de millions
d'argentins une bonne nouvelle pour
l'argentine deuxième pays d'amérique du
sud le plus touché par le virus
malgré l'isolément social strict mis en
place au début de la pandémie
et si depuis la fin octobre le pic de la
première vague semble avoir été passé
les autorités craignent l'arrivée d'une
deuxième avant la vaccination
il nous il ya des chiffres qui nous
inquiète c'est à dire que nous avons
très bien diminué depuis deux semaines
nous nous sommes stabilisés mais avec
une tendance à l'augmentation du nombre
de cas et quand ils augmentent il est
très difficile de le contenir
c'est donc la préoccupation du
gouvernement national et des
gouvernements provinciaux et le vaccin
doit nous encourager à prendre soin de
nous mêmes
et là le gouvernement argentin prévoit
de lancer la campagne de vaccination dès
la semaine prochaine sur le personnel de
santé
parallèlement des négociations sont en
cours avec le géant américain pfizer
pour la fourniture de son vaccin
développé avec l'allemand bjoern tech
buenos aires a également signer des
contrats d'achat avec université
d'oxford associé au laboratoire
astrazeneca et fait partie du mécanisme
international kovacs sous l'égide de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
permettant la fourniture de vaccins aux
pays en développement